let's talk about music yes
cinema not that stuff I'm talking about
music in anime the good [ __ ] with any
medium music can be used as a powerful
weapon and anime is no exception as all
through its history there have been some
absolutely beautiful examples littered
throughout
with this video I wanted to show a
little appreciation about some of the
ways music has been used in anime and
for anyone who got confused with my
animation video this is not meant to be
an in-depth breakdown this is not a deep
analysis this is just my casual music
appreciation thread so to clear things
up this time let's just name the video
things Giga appreciates about the use of
musical pieces in Japanese animation and
other miscellaneous things that are too
small to explore in a full business just
call this music in anime to make things
easier to digest this time I've
separated everything I want to talk
about it's a nice little bite-sized
categories so let's start things off
with unusual scores in anime by having a
unique quality to the soundtrack or even
a single song perhaps using a genre or
instrument you wouldn't normally
associate with that type of shown allows
the score to stand out even more and if
done right enhances the experience or
even revolutionizes the perception we
have between a type of music and a genre
of media I'm talking about the use of
bagpipes in fairytale how only Jarvis's
beats in samurai champloo sponsored by
her blessings has completely transformed
the Association we have of lo-fi hip-hop
beats to traditional samurai with
Eurobeat and initial D doing a very
similar thing to street racing and using
free jazz and Gundam Thunderbolts
perfectly blending the controlled chaos
of jazz with the actual chaos of a
battlefield strengthens by its
innovative use of mixing the die Jetix
jazz music our characters are listening
to with the non-diegetic score oh yeah
look at those big boy words a unique
score can add so much personality to a
show giving it that extra layer of
Appeal and I think the best example I
can use the hammer this point home is
when comparing the original harrassing
animator Helsing ultimate now anyone
who's watched both series can pretty
much agree that Helsing ultimate is
better in basically every way except for
arguably the music now this isn't to say
the music was bad while from it if we
look at the soundtrack that's mainly
comprised of orchestral tracks with the
occasional opera choir it's very suiting
for the themes and tone of the show but
that's kind of it
it does its job and does it well but
there's nothing really distinct or
unique about it and that's saying
something for a show about modern undead
vampires fighting nazi zombies now if we
listen to some of the tracks from the
original
garetty you just think oh man what is
this sexy piano is it getting hot in
here my being seduced damn Alucard you
smooth [ __ ] bottom me up and
take me home because I'm sure you're
about to show me a good time nice the
jazzy influence beats of the original
animes OST just has so much more
character and style in it than the epic
orchestral choir even if the latter is
more thematically suited and for that
reason it's just far more memorable when
I think of Helsing my mind immediately
goes back to these tracks even if I only
remember the events of Helsing ultimate
now I'm not saying the music always
needs to stand out sometimes its job is
to not detract from what's happening on
screen I'm just highlighting what it
could possibly add to it but there are
some anime where the music is definitely
one off if not the main stars of the
show music is the identity here I'm
talking about anime where the music is
such an essential part of this show's
identity that to replace the music would
be to essentially change the anime at
its core I'm talking about things like
Cowboy Bebop legendary musical numbers
rad wimps as contribution to your name
and Daft Punk's full-on animated album
in interstellar five five five five five
five five five five is this Domino's
Pizza I think a lot of these can be
attributed to the fact that in these
examples there were scenes in the anime
that were tweaked according to the music
as opposed to the music being composed
after the visuals had been done shink I
changed up scenes in the scripts
according to the songs rad wimps
composed with very similar things
happening in how karna and Watanabe were
working during bebop and interstellar
five-six-seven-eight was a music video
stretched over an album so yeah we could
play you say run over it but why would
we stupid question let's do it anyway
as I mentioned in my your name video
though the series that epitomizes this
the most is Flula coolies iconic Rock
soundtrack done by the pillows now I've
already said that the entire show feels
like a string of loosely connected music
videos I mean [ __ ] they certainly
weren't connected by plot
he says watching a red robot pop out of
a literal [ __ ] to suplex a bigger
robot had before being domesticated by
getting his head smashed in with a bass
guitar [ __ ] which is why one of the
few things that holds the series
together and gives a bit of cohesion is
the pillows as music the songs don't
feel like they are tracks written to
accompany any kind of visuals it feels
like just a full-on album as even the
tracks without vocals are instrumentals
of tracks with them but because of this
and because of the way the scenes were
integrated with the songs these songs
and the band are a central part of the
show it's still a point about all my
pessimism and skepticism surrounding the
newly announced sequels culminated in
this reaction for the trailer okay this
is looking all right I mean I'm so not
too excited cuz we don't really need a
sequel and I'm still highly wary cuz
none of the original team are behind
with entire soundtracks that we
associate with the show singular tracks
can also carry the same if not a much
heavier weight behind it and I'd like to
talk about that in this section called
songs we associate with stuff I know
what you're thinking kicker q literary
title genius I know we can look at how
music can be used to condition you into
feeling an emotional response let me
give you an example for anyone who's
seen an Ohana what do you feel when you
hear this track
[Music]
now I actually love an Ohana but even I
have wised up at the use of this song at
the end of every episode which plays at
the most emotional moments and because
of this every time we hear the track we
associate it with feeling sad and
emotional which builds and builds
culminating in the final episodes which
I can only describe as a full-on bukakke
of a Glee cry it's like with Pavlov's
dog the experiment in the 1890s were
even Pavlov managed to condition a dog
and is salivating by ringing a bell
every time the dog was given food to the
point where the dog would start
salivating at the bell sound even when
there was no food
I know Pavlov was probably there looking
at his dog like her what a stupid dog
what a stupid dog to be tricked by such
a simple trick and here humanity is 100
years later going and you see this in
use all over anime Clannad little
busters hell pretty much every ki show
and it's not just limited to sad
responses either you have the victory
music how about the shits about to go
down track and that character theme you
know the character has hired a guy to
follow them around with the boombox
everywhere so every time they appear on
screen the music shouts
by building association you build the
impact it can have on the audience you
can even boil it down to a melody for
example you can have the simple baby
version where you lay out a melody so
the audience builds some familiarization
then when you've really needed to hit
you inject the testosterone increase the
musical layers and you just let it rip
for full effect
[Music]
conversely can also be used to subvert
your expectations spoilers for Bleach
leach at one of the most unique victory
songs in Shonen I mean speaking of
hiring a boom box carrier each go hide a
full-on group of soul singers to follow
him about every time he was about to do
something awesome but one effective way
they were able to frame how completely
overpowered Aizen was as a villain was
to have him do good did you catch that
no it's not the fact that he called the
sword with one finger is that he
literally stops the bloody victory music
[ __ ] war I completely subverting the
association of that track with Ichigo
kicking ass it told us that there was
absolutely no safe space with this
villain which was a fantastic way to
build up how much of a threats this
individual was that was a long segment
what are we talking about next oh yeah
how could I forget that moment when the
opening song comes on or as I like to
call it the instant nuts moment you know
the drill we've reached the end it's
episode 24 no wait
episode 12 for all you hip Millennials
out there we're in extra time bases are
loaded and all hope looks lost but as
your main boy gears up for one final
attack you hear the first few beats of a
familiar tune it's the opening you look
over to your pal Tommy and easily clear
you both of you aren't prepared but you
both know what has to happen you give a
final proving nod and as the cheers run
down the spine in sync you both unzip
your pants because you know
but what I described was probably a 100%
accurate description of an experience
you've had in a climax of an anime and
this goes back to the music that we
associate with stuff as you have to
listen to an opening every time you
watch a show or you know at least once
if you end up skipping most openings
like me what this means is the way Wow
if you end up skipping most openings
like me if you end up skipping most
openings like me if you end up skipping
most openings like me what this means is
there is that guaranteed Association we
talked about earlier but because most
openings are designed to hype you up to
see the actual show that is the perfect
emotional Association to have which is
why playing the opening up the show's
climax is pretty much a guaranteed insta
come even though everyone uses this
technique lastly I wanted to quickly
mention bad anime with great arrestees
great music can elevates a good anime
into all new heights for what I finds
way more interesting is for me how it
can make bad anime kind of watchable and
enjoyable I remember watching the first
few seconds of guilty crown and being
immediately captivated by the opening
scene playing this beautiful song
[Music]
what a way to open a show you look at
this opening and you think man this is
gonna be something special this is
something I need to pay attention to
because it could turn out fantastic and
then the second half of the series hits
and it's just like but what gets me is
that despite the complete mess that the
show turned into there were still scenes
that grabs me when it had absolutely no
right to do so because it's hard not to
be just a little being grossed for a
second when you have beautiful tracks
alongside the absolutely bombastic
action music even if the scenes that
accompanied them were a [ __ ] mess of
a dog turd see that's the thing about
good music pieces it can make you for a
second
forgets by the rest of the [ __ ] show
surrounding a series to help and gross
you into a scene or a moments because
that's the power it has as much as I
have memes this scene from Tokyo ghoul
root aid even I have to admit that the
acoustic version of unravel is powerful
as [ __ ] never before has the voice of a
man who sounds like he permanently has
his bollocks trapped in a vice grip
sounded so soothing in fact the entire
soundtrack of Tokyo ghouls second season
out of nowhere was pretty damn awesome
compared to the previous season despite
the season itself being because you know
what taken by itself I actually really
really [ __ ] liked this scene the raw
musical piece paired with the slow
pacing of karnaki and the long shots
made for this soothing experience but
taken in the context of the rest of the
series and it's just like
[Music]
okay well about the rest of the
characters is Tokyo still running what I
want to end on is just talking about
zankyou no terror for a bit because to
this day it remains one of the most
unique scores I've heard in an anime and
one of my favorites not only taking
inspiration from beautiful atmospheric
Icelandic music which in itself is rare
in anime but juxtaposing that against
the hyper realistic art style in a
chaotic plot about terrorism which
really shouldn't have worked concreted
in some of the most beautiful and poetic
experiences I've had watching anime even
through its suspects writing
it's what cemented yoko kanno is my
favorite anime composer of all time
which is a very cliche answer in the
mountains of talented anime composers
out there but what this showed me is how
diverse she can be and after many many
years of outstanding work in her years
of working in anime was still able to
pull out something so entirely different
from anything we'd heard before
yet still have it be an absolute
masterpiece in the end what I really
wanted to hammer down is that music is
something I highly value not only in
anime but in my own work as well one of
my favorite compliments I can get from a
comment is hey I love the music choices
for this video and that's because I'm a
dumb [ __ ] who spends way too much time
trying to pick the perfect song choices
to match the exact tone I have my head
as I apply a lot of the things I've
talked about in my own work and I didn't
even get to talk about everything I
wanted to talk about music isn't always
at the forefront of a show sometimes
it's simply the scores job to support
the visuals character and plot which
takes the spotlight but I have a soft
spot for composition that goes that
extra mile so I hope in the least that
this video has reminded you about some
of your favorite uses of music in anime
because it's thanks to this magical word
I can proudly shove my phone playlist on
the speakers at a party to have people
turn around and ask Wow
where does this beautiful music come
from
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you very much this month -
elephant basil patrick mad sir Jerrica
tell Vincent Mooney now can and everyone
else a patron for helping to support me
for this month and making this video
possible this probably won't be the last
I will make a video with focus on music
in anime but these are just all the
small things I wanted to mention that I
feel didn't warrant their own video
anyway I'm going to go back in my cave
now till the end of year review so until
then I've been gig up and I will see you
all next time